We watch all the time in movies and TV shows as birds reach messages.
Whether it is a historical drama, or a Western drama in the series "Conflict of Arush" one has to ask
Can birds really communicate messages accurately?
Not to awaken you from your dreams of roses, but the crows, which are usually very intelligent,
Not likely birds to complete this task. Sorry John Snow! (Crow in the serial) But the fact is a bit amazing
Other birds, like the bath, are amazing in this work! Hence the name (bath pigeons)
In fact, the bathroom was used effectively 3,000 years ago, to advertise the exterior of the Olympic winner.
Translation of AraSense _
The bathroom has the innate ability to return home, which means that it will return to its nest for mating.
There were 1,800 km of bathroom flights. Because of this, use for centuries to send messages,
But with emphasis on the word "but" - and in general, the bathroom carries messages
One way only. The bathroom is away from home and, if needed, can be delivered
The messages come back to him again, because his innate instinct is to return home. So the idea
Sending a bird to whatever place you want is a little tricky. However, put it
Feed it with one location, and home with another, the bathroom trains to fly back and forth
Between two sites reliably.
The bath has a high visibility, uses the sun, stars, landscapes, scents and sound waves,
Perhaps also the earth's magnetic field to determine its habitat. Not to mention it
Apparently he has an internal compass that guides him. Because of his migration behavior,
He can train as a mass flight, unlike other birds require
Individual attention to completing the task.
Special thanks to audible.com for supporting this episode and giving you free audio books of your choice
On audible.com/asap. A leading provider of audio books
With more than 150,000 titles available for download around all branches of literature.
We recommend the book "How We Got to the Present" by Stephen Johnson, which deals with six innovations that created the modern world
You can download this book or others by choosing for free
On audible.com/asap. Special thanks to this site to make these videos see the light
Subscribe to the channel for more weekly science videos.